Ryan you've been open about your mental
health struggles yes I've talked about
which is rare for a fighter or any
professional athlete I don't even know
if I was the first one but I was the
first one publicly disabled I think
you're the first one to publicly do it
yeah what was going down I had panic
attacks and um my anxiety just got to
levels where
um I couldn't I couldn't handle it I
love that you're open but you know
that's my soapbox it's mental health and
I talk about mine and I suffer from uh
anxiety and OCD and how did you how are
you able to uh go up against whatever
your mental health struggles were uh it
just was a time obviously in learning
more about you go to therapy yeah I was
going to therapy and um I took all the
steps that I I just wanted to get better
being honest with yourself the truth and
then um yeah conversations with people
and understanding that other people have
went through a similar situation it kind
of eases off that that thing I'm alone
in a way like yeah okay okay he
understands so now you have the tools to
deal with it if it were to come back
again oh yeah 100